can we take you back 30 years to when
whitney houston changed the game with
her iconic rendition
of the national anthem
my part of singing the arrangements
that's the hard part
[Music]
whitney sang live in the stadium but
what audiences at home heard was a
pre-recorded track done a week before
in one take
[Applause]
the singer was only 27 when she took the
super bowl stage
next week marks the nine year
anniversary of whitney's tragic passing
at age 48. the coroner's man right
behind me contains the body of whitney
houston now there's a new documentary
whitney houston and bobby christina
didn't we almost have it all
airing saturday on lifetime they both
perished in
a bathtub in our exclusive look
whitney's former creative director
remembers
the night whitney died when i walked in
all i could hear was water under my feet
and then i saw her there i can't even
believe we're here talking about it
but today we pay tribute to another
legend christopher plummer died this
morning at home with his wife by his
side
the cause of death was a blow to the
head resulting from a fall
he was 91.
[Music]
perhaps his most famous role was as
captain von trapp in 1965's the sound of
music
well i'm not crazy about working a lot
with
children or indeed dogs as
the famous quote because all the
attention goes to them and none to you
and although i did like those kids
actually personally very much indeed
today co-star julie andrews told et i
have lost a cherished friend
knives out co-star chris evans posted
one of my favorite memories
was playing piano together between
setups he was a lovely man
and a legendary talent at 82 plummer was
the oldest actor ever to receive an
academy award for his role in beginners
he famously thanked his wife in his
acceptance speech for keeping him
in line my long-suffering wife
elaine who deserves the nobel peace
prize
for coming to my rescue every day of my
life thank you so much
of course i'm i'm a naughty boy i'm i've
been bad all my life and she
holds puts me in line i think it's great
what she does she was extraordinary